what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel today I am going
to be reacting to another blind date
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way in and yeah let's
get started what you've been drinking um
I'm actually not on the Alcohol today
okay so I've been just having some um
water with some limes oh okay
I will have a Bacardi one with cranberry
I think he's out of her League am I
wrong no no like he's better looking
than her
slightly Yeah by a point or two yeah
I've got Cuban room that's right yeah
[Music]
oh he brought her flowers out of that's
so nice I love flowers
I'm so glad thank you so much that's
beautiful but I wouldn't recommend this
uh because I'm sure she'll treat him
like [ __ ] as a thank you let me just
let's see the flowers aren't as
beautiful as you
oh no okay I'm just gonna give you a tip
guys we don't like to be put on a
pedestal so the guys that treat us like
a queen when you just met us and you
don't know anything about us it doesn't
make sense I mean let me apologize on
behalf of women but we don't like that
[ __ ] so bringing flowers to a girl you
don't know don't do all that you don't
have to there's a girl she's letting hit
for free look at her I guarantee that
guarantee
the gentleman be the gentleman and buy
the whole meal that
[Music]
um
the lady likes me for who I am she's not
gonna worry about what's in my footballs
in my wallet no that's true and
um we can always just go hard from
hearts on everything
I'm very traditional
traditional women don't weigh more than
150 pounds
and although I don't mind being modern
in a traditional way man should pay and
listen the way I see it is like you
treat me good I'll give you the world
[ __ ] that's cap that's cap I guarantee
there's some guy that's treating her
like [ __ ] that honestly she has given
the world up check your friend zone this
is what my my number one fear is would I
be losing but if me and you were still
awesome yeah yeah
[Music]
so what do you do well stop taking
things like that so I'm actually doing
agency works at the moment but um things
pick up and obviously I've been living
in this YMCA for a little while
okay so yeah it's just trying to pick
myself back up again okay so you're kind
of getting back on your feet basically
um to be honest
um I was homeless at one point
um I lived on the street for like two
years wow because um obviously my old
Queen she passed
that's one reason that's why I was
homeless right he's a widow is that I
mean my old Queen okay okay
that's so sad oh it's a bit I was always
the Mommy's boy
it was a September
oh a mama's boy I thought he meant like
a wife okay this disease that absolutely
ruined her she
had 28 operations she had multiple times
her stomach cut out you know multiple
times I slept in the hospital I've
actually built up a fear now of
hospitals and then I got called from one
of my aunties saying that she's not come
back out of hospital yet because they're
diagnosed her with the cancer this time
um
okay I'm not I really don't want to be a
[ __ ] but I don't know if I would lead
if I was homeless for two years because
my mom died I'm not trying to be rude
it's just like I know a lot of guys
whose mom moms died that were mama's boy
like my Dad loved his mother oh my God
that's the saddest I've ever seen my dad
but he wouldn't let himself get homeless
for two years oh no and then I
it's hard because I understand where the
men are coming from where it's like why
Court these women traditionally if
they're not traditional but I do think
in general like dating advice women
don't tend to like guys that are cheap
and so if you're trying to split the
bill it just makes you seem cheap and
women don't like that so if you want I
understand why the guys do it but I just
think if you want the best outcomes I
wouldn't recommend doing that and I feel
like he's kind of dropping the ball a
little bit as like sweet as this is you
know yeah
like a winning
I actually had to sleep
with leaves covered over me wrapped up
in the sheet in a garden
I was crying my heart out in the morning
for like missing my mum
that's why I'm here that I want to find
that person that not reflects my mum but
you know somebody who can just have that
warm love like she did and if I could
have that back
that'll be the best thing in life
as they say life is what you're making
life is how you make it but you don't
have those obstructions anymore do you
where I live at the moment inside the
YMCA they actually have helped me out so
much
thank you go in halves in the bill
usually that would have been a complete
No-No for me
[Music]
he's got nothing to be ashamed of
whatsoever
he's very romantic and I'm not used to
that at all the whole day I think I
probably maybe I read this wrong
brother's game is working brother's game
is working I might have read it wrong
guys sometimes your girl can be wrong
how sweet about a million times give me
that and I'll pay the rest on cards yet
[Music]
would you like to see each other again I
would say yes oh of course I'd like to
see you again you're a gorgeous girl
thank you oh that was sweet that's it I
thought he was doing it all wrong I
thought he's doing it all wrong but I
will say I do think it's a bit of a red
flag that she's like I'm not used to the
romance like I I feel like he might be
friend zoned down the line but that was
really cute little first date so you
know what I love love I'm happy it's
working out for them
um let me know in the comments what you
guys think subscribe to the channel like
the video on your way out ring that
notification Bell and I'll talk to you
next time as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible